cnn openly calls for a social crackdown
on fox news
team biden gets more and more radical
and trump's impeachment team
falls apart i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet visit expressvpn.com
speaking of which you know i've been
talking about expressvpn on this show
for months so
seriously why have you not just gone and
got an express vpn yet i will tell you
this there's never been a more important
time to protect your digital rights you
can see
the big tech pros they are all over you
they don't like you very much
you should be protecting your data from
them you should be protecting your data
from hackers a lot of people sitting
home right now a lot more people working
online that means a lot more fertile
ground
for hackers to mine instead why not
protect your data with express
vpn did you believe a vpn isn't for you
because you can use the internet just
fine without a vpn well
anytime you go online your internet
service provider can see every single
site you're visiting
are you confused about how it works
don't be expressvpn is an app for
computers and smartphones it encrypts
your network
data and reroutes it through a secure
server that means you can use the
internet more anonymously without having
your activity tracked do you think vpns
are complex only for tech experts
take it from me they're not with
expressvpn you launch the appy tap just
one button to protect yourself it really
is
that simple i trust expressvpn to
protect my online data because they're
rated number one by cnet and wired and
they stand for my values now is the time
for you to take a stance head on over to
expressvpn.com
ben take back your privacy and get three
extra months free on a one year package
when you use
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com that's
expressivevpn.com3 extra months for free
again visit expressvpn.com right this
very instant okay so
we are watching as the left basically
uses its newfound power
in order to call for crackdowns on
everybody they disagree with and they're
telling you that it's not important you
know because
everybody that they disagree with
they'll still have outlets it's fine
they'll still have places
that they can go and then the next step
is once they have essentially
forced everybody into an ideological
silo then they blow up the silo
and this is what we saw with parlor from
the left the left said you know you
don't like how twitter handles its
business well just go have your own
social media platform so a bunch of
conservatives said
all right sounds good bunch of
libertarians and they formed parlor
and then the next move was well you know
they're a little too open over there
what if you just de-platform them
and we see this routinely throughout the
media the first move is
you know you conservatives why can't you
make it on the left-wing why can't you
just join up with left-wing outlets
and then conservatives try and they say
no no you can't come in here because
you're conservative that means you're
bad so they say okay you know what we're
going to go form our own outlets
and we're going to use the normal
methods of distribution
in order to achieve a market share and
then the same people who ousted them who
threw them
outside of the house they say okay well
now you guys are so bad that you really
shouldn't have access to the market
at all you can see this happening in
real time
and it's been happening for a while but
really it's coming to a head right now
because every crisis is an opportunity
for the left i said the day that january
6th took place the day that the
the violation of the capital took place
i said
that that act of evil was going to have
tremendous repercussions it was going to
be used
by the hard left as an excuse to
basically censor everybody they didn't
like and they weren't going to restrict
that
to people who actually engaged in
criminal activity they weren't even
going to restrict that to arguments that
may have fostered the criminal activity
instead they were going to use that to
go after everybody they don't like
because let's face it folks in the media
purvey things that are not true
a lot they do it a lot it depends on the
narrative
how many members of the cnn staff spent
months claiming that jacob blake was an
unarmed black man who'd been shot
by white police officers for no reason
pretty much all
of them and how many members of the cnn
staff
how many of their big anchors claim that
that andrew cuomo was the greatest
governor in all the land four months at
a time
while rhonda sanders in florida was a
scourge virtually all of them
they they propel whatever narrative they
want to propel at any given time
and they will fib to do it or they'll
twist the facts to do it or ignore
countervailing fact
in order to do that but the thing is
that if those countervailing facts are
brought to light by anybody else or if
there's a narrative that they see from
the other side that they don't like very
much
then that other side must be silent so
brian stelter
who is a sort of bellwether for the the
woke left infusing itself into
mainstream media stelter didn't used to
be
quite as radical as he has become i was
on his show just a few years ago and he
said
you know you know you have your outlet
daily wire why don't people like you why
don't conservatives try to go into
mainstream media and i literally said to
him
anybody at cnn gonna try and hire me you
think brian and the answer of course was
no
well now brian stilter has gotten to the
point where he is openly calling
for a crackdown on fox news he's openly
calling for a crackdown
on people who disagree or on people he
believes are pervading false information
now here is the thing
you have seen a shift in the language
being used by folks when it comes to
what sort of information should be given
a platform and which sort of information
should receive distribution they shifted
it's it's a subtle linguistic shift
there are a couple of major subtle
linguistic shifts that are happening
right now
as we speak and we're going to elucidate
them on today's show one is the shift
from misinformation okay so it was
misinformation and disinformation so
disinformation campaigns
really were a were a the idea was those
were a foreign weapon it was foreign
propaganda so a disinformation campaign
was the soviets putting out false
information that they hoped would be
eaten up by the left in the united
states and then propagated to wider
audience that was disinformation
right disinformation means actual lies
things that are not true
then there is quote unquote
misinformation misinformation which is
the term that is now being used in the
media all the time
it's a term that means stuff i don't
like right maybe some of it is not true
maybe some of it is true but i just
don't like the narrative
so the shift from disinformation which
is the idea that it is being propagated
by foreign power in order to push a
particular agenda that is anti-american
in scope
the shift from disinformation right
deliberate attempts to falsify
to misinformation meaning information
that i disagree with or information
that you know i i think is wrong right
that shift
is pretty subtle but it's being used at
an extraordinarily
rapid clip is being adopted by members
of the mainstream media as an excuse to
shut down competitors
and not only that if you have ever
uttered something that they say was not
true
then the idea is that you must be shut
down as a human being so it doesn't
matter that again cnn has propagated
absolute untruths
and cnn propagated lies about covington
catholic cnn propagated lies
about black lives matter see an
unpropagated propagated lies about trump
cnn propagated
lies about bush cnn propagates lies
sometimes does that mean that cnn should
be de-platformed that they should lose
their ability to distribute information
of course not but
that is where brian seltzer is going to
go so now brian stelter says
you know what we should reduce the reach
of people that i disagree with basically
and people who are on the other side of
the aisle because it's not as though
they have a consistent standard of truth
it's not like okay here are the people
who lie all the time and then here are
the people who tell the truth all the
time
and it's just that they believe that
people who are of their opinion are pure
as the driven snow and people who are
not of their opinion
if you can find any hook upon which to
hang
their banning you just go for it so here
is brian stelter on reliable sources
over the weekend
big tech platforms say they are removing
lies about vaccines
and stamping out stop the steel bs and
cueing on cult content
now do these private companies have too
much power sure many people would say
yes of course they do
but reducing a liar's reach is not the
same as censoring freedom of speech
freedom of speech is different than
freedom of reach
and algorithmic reach is part of the
problem okay so
he then extended that over to fox news
right he basically suggested
that fox news itself should have its
freedom of reach
withdrawn and when he says that it is
not a first amendment violation to
restrict people's reach what he's really
talking about here are places like daily
wire or places
like the federalist or anything that is
right of center on facebook
right when he says that what he means
the freedom of reach is not the same as
freedom of speech
he's basically saying that what we need
is for unofficial social media censors
to stop the distribution of information
and he's saying that's not the
government he's right it's not the
government but
it is just as damaging as the government
when the town square
is facebook right facebook is not like
the comments section over at
daily wire because daily wire is in fact
a publication right we have a particular
point of view it is open and obvious
where our point of view is
facebook is much more like a town square
it was designed to be a town square when
they decide that they are going to
censor particular points of view
and they're going to do so basically
with the permission of the government
because the government has given them
these carve outs under section 230
then they are violating their core
tenant okay the freedom of speech
does not cease to apply as a principle
in places where it's supposed to be the
chief functioning principle
so members of the left are playing this
little game here and again i'm
libertarian on a lot of the stuff i
think the private companies should have
an awful
lot of freedom to do what it is that
they want i also think that rival public
companies
should also be able to private companies
should also be able to do what they want
i think the parlor should exist and
twitter should exist
i don't think that people should be
platforming them when you have neutral
service providers that are denying
service to one side or the other based
purely on politics which is what this is
then things are getting really really
ugly really really fast and the only
answer is going to be a re
either a rewriting of section 230 or a
reinterpretation of section
230 of the communications decency actors
we'll get to in just a second
but it's the principle that's amazing
here so you have reliable sources right
this is supposed to be a free speech
program saying freedom of speech is
really important but what we would love
is for private companies
to restrict that freedom of speech
private companies need to stop
people from seeing information that i
don't like and so you've had members of
the cnn crew suggest that for example
comcast
should simply get rid of the ability to
distribute fox news
you've had anchors on cnn claim the same
thing
i've never seen anything from fox news
along these lines about cnn or msnbc by
the way
for all the talk about how sean hannity
and laura ingram and tucker carlson look
at these
look at these opinion hosts with their
strong viewpoints
not one of them so far as i'm aware has
ever called on comcast to d platform cnn
or msnbc
but cnn and msnbc are calling for this
sort of stuff and they're calling for it
pretty regularly joe scarborough called
for it last week
on msnbc so to meeker brzezinski you're
seeing stelter call for it now
when they say that freedom of reach is
not the same as freedom of speech that's
sort of like the argument that freedom
of religion
should basically be restricted to inside
your house right you should only be free
to practice your religion inside your
house if you go outside your house and
you're acting as you would in the
business world and you're making
decisions in your business based on your
religious precepts well now that's not
freedom of religion anymore because
after all you know you're acting in the
public okay well if you restrict
somebody's freedom of reach
to essentially zero then what of what
value is their freedom of speech at that
point
then you've got a real problem on your
hands but again the goal here is not
a an exchange of decent ideas or even an
overton window that is better police
the idea is that people i disagree with
should be silent so oliver darcy's
a nice guy but oliver darcy he was on
cnn and he says you know we have to stop
comparing fox and msnbc
we have to stop comparing that because
fox should basically be the platform
while msnbc should not here's oliver
darcy on cnn
making claims about rival networks it's
it's an amazing thing
to equate um what msnbc does or some of
these other outlets do with what fox
does
is nonsensical uh there are outlets that
have opinion hosts but they're playing
in the
real world within the world of facts and
in reality and fox is spinning its own
reality and to suggest that there is an
uh equivalence between the two i i think
it is not accurate
and um and something we should really be
careful to avoid
oh really it's not accurate i'm old
enough to remember when during the
michael brown protests
an entire panel of people on cnn held up
signs that said hands up don't shoot and
commentators like sally cohen were
actually doing the hands up don't shoot
them which is a total
fraudulent lie it was a fabrication top
to bottom
and he's saying that on cnn the the
network of covington catholic right they
had to pay a settlement
to nick sandman for slandering him
they're not the same no they are the
same they're exactly the same it's just
that you like the views on msnbc and cnn
and you don't like the views on fox news
and so that has to be silenced
hey over at the washington post they're
doing the same thing so margaret
sullivan is the media columnist over at
the washington post
she has a piece today basically saying
that everybody that she doesn't like
should be silenced and that's not cancel
culture
so the left likes to play this game
where they like to cancel people and
then claim the canceled culture does not
exist
which always makes it kind of fun uh and
uh and karmic
when they themselves are cancelled which
almost inevitably happens within about
six months of saying cancel culture
doesn't exist you'll see there's this
this hilarious pattern in which folks on
the left say cancel culture is not real
and then five months later somebody
unearths an old tweet that was bad
and suddenly they're canceled by the
same left that they were cheering on a
moment ago
because the mob loves you until mom
doesn't love you anymore so margaret
sullivan has this piece over at the
washington post
and her idea is the same as stelter's
which is we should just withdraw the
means of distribution
from people i don't like and that's
going to have no consequences whatsoever
for the american body politic other than
good so here's what she writes
according to washington examiner's eddie
scary nothing less than a social justice
mob descended on politico after it gave
a guest editing slot to right-wing
flamethrower ben shapiro uh first of all
cool nickname
that's really thank you for that also
flamethrower like have you listened to
five minutes of this show
sir of course not of course not none of
these peop these people do this all the
time
rush limbaugh racist they they're
listening five seconds of rush limbaugh
they've never even heard anything rush
limbaugh's ever said by the way that was
actually the first conversation i ever
had with elizabeth warren long before
she was a senator
she's a professor at harvard law school
and i met her at the top of the w hotel
when i was being recruited for harvard
law
and she and i kind of met and she and
she
said oh yeah you're the one who wrote
that books had written a book already
about bias on college campuses
and she started talking about rush
limbaugh and have you ever listened to
rush limbaugh
and she was like no i said so why are
you talking about rush limbaugh
but that's the perspective here i'm a
right-wing flamethrower because margaret
sullivan who i'm sure has never listened
to anything i've ever said
calls me a right-wing flamethrower and
the goal of calling me a right-wing
flamethrower of course is the idea that
i should be platforms so she says
scary mock those including many of
politico's employees who thought shapiro
never should have been in charge of the
site's popular playbook newsletter
even for a day such objections are an
effort to silence conservative voices
scary claims in another piece
liberal journalist journalists quote
believe one side of the political
spectrum to be legitimate
and the other should be given as few
opportunities to have their opinions
heard as possible
in other words it's all part of a
cancelled culture the catchphrase for
how the mass is supposedly gang up to
silence provocative voices
i happen to think that the politico
staffers were right to oppose their news
organization
granting its imprimatur to someone with
shapiro's history of performative
bigotry
i guess that is my history performative
it doesn't matter that i've given full
speeches ripping the alt-right
it does not matter that i oppose the
so-called muslim none of that matters
right because she doesn't know any of
that doesn't care she doesn't care
by the way breaking news to margaret
sullivan she writes for the washington
post
she doesn't like that outlets grant
granted their imprimatur to me
in 2016 i wrote an op-ed for the
washington post margaret so you might
want to talk with your editors over
there
in any case she says scary is entitled
to his opinion and so are the objectors
at politico and in in defense of the
idea that i should be banned she cites a
tweet from 2010
it is now 2021. okay just checking your
calendar
uh one tweet from 11 years ago that i've
explained 1 000 times about the israeli
arab conflict she cites that
literally i have a piece on the website
a daily wire something no journalist i
am aware of or opinion journalist i'm
aware of has ever done
i have posted every single bad thing i
think i have ever said and then either
explained it
or apologized for it like in writing
okay so she cites that this is always
their go-to is they find a tweet from
2010 right
like that's nuts okay and
then another tweet uh in 2019 it wasn't
even a tweet
it was a uh it was a a statement on this
show in which i was talking about beta
o'rourke's view
that he would be able to essentially get
rid of religion in public life
a better work said that he wanted to
remove all non-profit statuses from any
church or synagogue
that did not go along with his woke
social justice nonsense
and i made an argument that beta
o'rourke was going to go after religious
schools remove their nonprofit status go
after churches remove their nonprofit
status
and then then the left's next move would
be to declare that if you did not
educate your child
in the ways they wanted to educate your
child they would come to your front door
and i said anybody who tries to take my
kid away from me on the basis of
teaching my kid values that i don't want
to talk to my kids i will meet them at
the door at the gun
okay i don't disagree with that
sentiment i fully agree with me i was
right
okay so she cites that as reason why i
should not write for politico
she says in america all these people get
to talk because of the first amendment
the government won't shut them down
that doesn't mean they're immune to
other forms of accountability though and
here's where we get into the fun part
for folks on the left they are the
accountability they grab control of the
institutions
then they bar you from the institutions
then when you build alternative
institutions
they air raid them and that that is the
that is the
pattern that we are seeing over and over
in american society and then if you
complain about it then you're whining
right then you are then you're part of a
victimhood culture
hilariously enough there's a piece over
at axios about this by jim vanderhey the
other day where he cited me he said to
tucker carlson
about the new right-wing talking point
that the right is under assault
from the institutional centers of
american culture the right wing
had centralized around this talking
point and i emailed
i emailed the folks at access i was like
jim vanderhey the guy who wrote this
piece
three weeks ago three weeks ago you
wrote a piece in which you said blue
america is a sentence in every
institutional area of america
and it was going to mean a rethinking of
thought and speech in the united states
and then you wonder why we're a little
paranoid just because we're paranoid
does not mean you're not out to get us
because you guys are and you're saying
it every day
this sort of gaslighting where it's like
we're going to destroy your career we're
going to deplatform you why are you so
whiny about it
it's like well that's not whining that's
a sensing a threat and we're going to
we here at the daily wire and other
conservative places we're going to
mobilize to fight against that threat
and we are going to use every market
possibility to fight against that threat
we're going to build alternative
institutions
we are going to make way for thoughts
that you guys do not want propagated
tough bleep gonna get some more of this
in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that
you don't want to be spending time
in line at an auto shop right now an
auto parts shop like
you don't by the way you don't ever you
go over to the local
auto parts shop and then you wait in
line you get to the front of the line
they have to order the part anyway
they charge you too much for it instead
why not just use the same thing you use
for everything else right now use the
interwebs rockauto.com
it is much easier than walking into a
store and someone's demanding quick
answers to complex questions about your
car
and then usually they just order the
part anyway instead head on over to
rockauto.com at your desk and in your
pocket
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts that's the
you can get at rock auto for example
let's say for example you needed the
delphi fg 1456 fuel pump assembly for a
2005 to 2010 honda odyssey that'll cost
you like 354 bucks at a big chain store
at rockauto.com that'll cost you 217
bucks they're a family business they've
been serving auto parts customers online
for 20 years
great catalog to make it easy to order
head on over to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
truck right shapiro in there how did you
hear about xbox so they know that we
sent you again that is rockauto.com
right you appear on that how did you
hear about usbox so they know that we
sent you okay so margaret sullivan
continues along these lines she says
that it does not cancel culture
if we cancel you she says night after
night fox news offers primetime viewers
it's leftist assault on speech show
josh halley who needed only a few days
to find a new publisher for his book
subsequently blasted the muslin of
america in an opinion piece in the
widely read new york post have any of
these people been silenced
hardly and then margaret sullivan
hilariously enough quotes
parker malloy of media matters yes
there's an objective
an objective non-partisan non-silencing
site media matters
exists only to silence voices it does
not like all media matters does
every day each day they hire people to
just watch shows like this one
clip them out of context and then attack
our advertisers and our subscribers
that's all they do all day so she quotes
them as a source for why cancel culture
doesn't exist
and my goodness why don't you just quote
oj simpson on why murder never happens
like really as parker malloy puts it
despite getting a spot on the front page
of the fourth largest newspaper in the
u.s
coverage across the entire fox news
lineup a new book deal and audience of
more than half a million followers on
twitter and a lengthy list of credits on
imdb
hallie would like you to believe he is a
man without a voice okay so the goal
here for the but here's the thing
you guys want to take away all of those
things all of those things it's not as
though you're saying
yeah you know josh halley he you know if
he loses his simon schuster book
contract
i'm glad that there are other publishers
out there willing to pick up josh
halley's book contract
you are sad about this you are angry you
don't want ragnary to exist you don't
want fox news to exist you don't want
daily wire to exist quoting the person
from media matters to the effect that
josh halley is not being silenced
all media matters does all day long is
attempt to silence people they don't
like
okay so here is what margaret sullivan
concludes i talked to the leading first
amendment lawyer and scholar jameel
jaffer about all this last week
jeffrey thinks a lot of these complaints
are misguided they spring he said from a
misunderstanding of what the first
amendment is all about
the point of the first amendment is to
take these kinds of debates out of the
hands of government and put them in the
hands of private citizens
says jaffer a columbia university law
professor and director of the night
first amendment institute
it's not subverting the first amendment
to criticize a politician or a cable
news host or a right-wing provocateur
that's the whole point of a first
amendment
nor is it a subversion of free speech
values for news organizations to make
editing decisions or for social media
platforms to make and enforce rules
there's the jump i love that part so i
agree you can criticize me as much as
you want nobody's saying margaret
sullivan should lose her spot
over at the washington post for being
the world's crappiest columnist i'm not
saying she should
i think she should keep that i think
they should keep paying her to write pap
everybody has to make a living in this
country okay but i love that she says
it's not even a subversion of not the
first amendment free speech
values it's not a subversion of free
speech values
for social media platforms to make and
enforce rules
amazing she says these nuanced views
don't get much airtime in the outrage
factories of cable news and talk radio
jaffar said it's important we should
tolerate diverse views we benefit from a
public square that includes ideas for
making us uncomfortable
oh but but she doesn't want that does
she she doesn't at all
she says it would help if journalists
push back more effectively cnn's pamela
brown gave a master class in her
devastating interview with madison
cawthorne
even if that sort of pushback becomes
the norm news organizations should be
wary of handing these charlatans a
megaphone so instead of just rebutting
people you don't like
instead you should just not let them on
the air she says you can call that
cancel culture if you want i call it
responsibility
uh yes responsibility is making sure you
never have to hear an opposing point of
view or rebut it you can just ban them
outright
excellent i definitely trust these
people why in the world would people on
the right be paranoid that you guys are
trying to ruin our lives
okay so here's the thing it really isn't
even about margaret sullivan going after
me
or about cnn going after fox news the
thing is everybody knows this bleeds
down
to the common person this bleeds down to
people who are not in media see i do
have an outlet we've spent millions of
dollars building this outlet
right the outlet that we have is a very
powerful outlet
it is still reliant on social media
platforms to allow us to exist
right it's possible that you are
listening to the show right now on apple
it is possible that you are listening to
the show right now or watching it over
at youtube
it is possible that you're watching it
over at facebook right all of those are
platforms all of those platforms
started off as places that pledged
themselves to open and honest debate
we are still reliant on them but here's
the thing we we still
have our own platform we still have the
ability for you to subscribe that's why
i've been encouraging everybody if
you're on the conservative side of the
aisle you need to go and pay direct for
the stuff you like
because the left is going to try and
take it away on all the other mechanisms
of distribution
but put us aside because we in the media
it's our job to find a way to get our
information to you
and in a free country which the united
states thank god still is
at least in most ways we are going to
find a way to get you that information
with your help but what this really is
about is not about me or about tucker or
about any of the people
who are in the media sphere what this
really is about is about you it's about
you
working your day job at a normal
corporation it is you working
your day job at a school it's about you
working
your day job not being a politically
volatile person just posting on facebook
every once in a while
living in fear that your corporation is
going to crack down on you for saying
the wrong thing at work
that somebody at work is going to find
out that you voted for trump or one to a
trump rally that somebody at work
is going to find out that you listen to
this show so you make sure that you
listen to it during your off hours
and this is about you worrying that that
your friends and neighbors
are going to treat you as a leper a
social leper
if you happen to have different points
of view see in order for the first
amendment protections to abide
in order for the legal protections of
government not to get involved in your
free speech to continue
you need an attitude that is pro-free
speech
you see how margaret sullivan conflates
the first amendment legally with free
speech as a value those are not the same
thing
free speech as a value is a commitment
by the common person by corporations
by your boss to the idea that there can
be some descent in the workplace to the
idea
that there can be open conversation that
they're not going to fire you for
something that has nothing to do with
your ability to do your job
it means that you among your friends
you're not going to attempt to cancel
people in your social circle
just because you have disagreements
about tax rates right
or because they voted for somebody that
you don't like
right it takes commitment by everybody
to this certain level
of diversity of values right it does
there have to be certain baseline
because that diversity of value stands
atops it stands atop a broader universal
value
right about which there can be no
diversity and that is a value that free
speech matters that in a free society we
should be able to treat each other
decently and still disagree about things
that's the thing you got margaret
sullivan calling me a right-wing
flamethrower
how many people i've had on this show
who disagree with me tons and tons and
tons the sunday special
nearly every week somebody who disagrees
with me in some way
margaret sullivan is calling me the
right wing flamethrower i'm not the one
who's shutting the window
i'm not the one who's welding closed the
door is margaret sullivan doing that
and praising herself for doing that and
it's happening every day around the
water cooler
people are self-censoring people are
silencing themselves it is bad for the
country
the left is happy about it because they
feel as though they are in control and
they are in control
there is a pew poll that was taken last
year you know what it showed it showed
that the plurality of
every group politically in the united
states outside of woke progressives
believes they have to self-censor every
single one liberals moderate liberals
say that they have to self-censor what
they believe
at work because they're afraid of the
repercussions the only people who never
have to self-censor are the most radical
leftists
those people can say whatever the hell
they want they can say whatever they
want
okay and that is going to destroy the
country it truly is
okay so here is is how this manifests
for the media so what the media love to
do
in order to make this happen everybody
understands this really ugly thing that
is happening right now
even people who are sort of mainstream
liberals understand that this is an ugly
thing that's why you had the harper's
weekly letter
last year about 150 academics on the
left all of whom voted for biden i'm
sure
not single trump voter among them wrote
a letter to crying cancel culture
and the left went after them right all
of those people
are being lumped in now with people on
the right and all those people are being
lumped in
with the worst offenders of people who
violate sort of norms of decency
because the goal here is to shut the
overton window so small that no one fits
in it except for the locust
of everybody on a social level so if you
have the right political values by the
way
then you have a free pass to do whatever
you want and if you don't have the right
political values then you have a
pre-pass to do nothing and we will dig
up everything you wrote back in 2002
and we will use it to ruin you so let's
take a couple of examples
so right now in politics there are two
stories one is going to receive
significant media attention one is not
going to receive significant media
attention
at least not in the long haul again the
one that's not going to receive
significant attention long haul it's a
story right now so it's gotten a little
bit of mainstream media attention to be
fair
it's not going to receive any over the
course of the next two weeks
the co-founder of the lincoln project
right the lincoln project is a bunch of
supposedly ex-republicans who went
democrats
wasted tens of millions of bucks
targeting particular republicans across
the country
and then claimed victory after the last
election cycle it's sort of the most
not only never trump and anti-trump but
anti-republican they were going after
people like susan collins in maine
and so it turns out that the lincoln
project which is basically a bunch of
grifters
who suggested that they were going to
say nasty things about republicans and
raise lots of money to do it it turns
out that the co-founder
john weaver has now been condemned by
the lincoln project
in the wake of allegations that the
long-time gop strategist made
unsolicited sexual overtures to several
young men
including one who was 14 years old at
the time he received sexual messages
from weaver
the group finally after i mean there are
reports about this for months by the way
finally the group put out a statement on
sunday when it became clear they
couldn't keep running away from the
story
saying john weaver had a secret life
that was built on a foundation of
deception at every level he's a predator
a liar and an abuser we extend our
deepest sympathies to those who are
targeted by his deplorable and predatory
behavior
the lincoln project rose to prominence
last year as they campaigned against
trump
and others who supported him weaver 61
helped co-found the group
he had previously worked on the
presidential campaigns for john mccain
and john kasich
the new york times published a report
sunday morning based on interviews with
21 men
who alleged weaver sent them unwanted
provocative messages or solicited that
solicited them for sex
often in exchange for the promise of
professional help the new york times
story followed reports
beltweaver's behavior from earlier this
month including one by the american
conservatives ryan
gordursky on january 11th and by axios
on january 15th
his original response weavers was that
he was a gay man
which is the get out of jail free card
of sexual abuse at least for a couple of
weeks right is that if you're a straight
guy supposedly who engages in predatory
behavior
claiming you're gay is somehow supposed
to give you cover most gay men are not
predators
when i say most i mean nearly all gay
men are not predators so that's a pretty
pathetic
defense there by uh by weaver
okay so on sunday the lincoln project
noted weaver was never around the other
members
he said we are grateful beyond words
that at no time was john weaver in the
physical presence of any other member of
the lincoln project okay fine
so this will be out of the news i
promise within three days
and the lincoln project will continue as
though nothing ever happened
because they have issued the the
denunciation of their co-founder
and they will move on okay maybe that's
right maybe that's right maybe they
never knew seriously i'm gonna give them
the benefit of the down maybe they never
knew any of this stuff was true
maybe they never knew that any of the
rumors were true fine
okay do you think that the right is
going to be if they were a right-wing
group
you really think that they'd be let go
within the next few days watch watch the
news
you'll see the mentions of lincoln
project in the news will go like this
right they're just going to crater
meanwhile
every republican in america will be
asked about the crazy person
marjorie taylor green every single
republican for the next couple of years
will be asked every time marjorie taylor
greens has a crazy thing
to denounce marjory taylor greene
because that's the way this game works
is that if there is somebody on the
right who's crazy and you need somebody
crazy you can focus in on so you can
slander the entire republican party and
every conservative with that person
you just keep focusing in on that person
right john weaver will not be in the
news
two days from now marjorie taylor green
will be in the news for the next couple
of years at minimum
no matter how many times people say that
she's a crazy person because by the way
she's a crazy person we'll get to this
in just one second
first let us talk about a big thing that
you can do
this year a big important thing you can
get life insurance you need to do it are
you responsible human
if you're responsible human make sure
that you get the life insurance your
family requires
policy genius can help you check off two
big items with ease
compare life insurance rates and say 50
or more in the process that means more
cash to put
toward the things you care about plus
there's absolutely no hassle the
licensed experts work for you not the
insurance companies so they can offer
unbiased advice when you need it here's
how it works first you head on over to
policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes
from top insurers to find your best
price
policy genius will then compare policies
starting at as little as a buck a day
you might even be eligible to skip that
in-person medical exam once you apply
the policy genius team handles all the
paperwork and the red tape if you hit
any speed bumps during the application
process
they'll take care of everything for you
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across over
1600 reviews
on trustpilot and google so if you're
worried that march is just around the
corner and you've barely gotten anything
done
take a deep breath policy genius will
help you make the most of this
short month in minutes just go save 50
or more by comparing quotes policy
genius.com get the life insurance you
and your family
require all right we're going to be
getting into more of the contrast
between
the material used to slander the left
and the material used to slander the
right not quite the same
we'll get to that in a second first
daily wear as you know i keep saying we
have to push into the culture we need to
fight back on every front
one of the ways we are doing that is we
are getting involved in entertainment
content that is why we put out our first
film run hide fight exclusively
for daily wire members you can catch
that over on dailywire.com on our mobile
app on our streaming apps at apple tv
and roku if you're not a daily wear
member yet
use promo code rhf to get 25 off that is
our hf for run hide fight for 25
off i've been hearing from tons of
members of the audience they love the
film
because it's really good it's a really
really good film and the critics don't
like it which is the kind of stuff we
want to make stuff that critics
aren't going to love but you will you
can catch it over on dailywear.com
on our mobile app on our streaming apps
at apple tv and roku if you're not a
daily wire member yet use promo code rhf
to get 25
off that is rhf for 25 off you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
alrighty so here is the thing you've got
the entire the entire left
basically saying that everybody on the
right has to answer for it's
its worst members meanwhile the rule on
the rule on the left is that you never
have to answer for any of your worst
members it's pretty amazing actually
yeah i've been hearing from folks on the
left why don't you guys on the right why
don't you just
get rid of your worst folks and i say
well you know when steve king said his
white supremacy
defense comment right when he said that
thing some of us
went full out for his opponent in a
primary he got primaried he lost
that seat now belongs to to feenstra in
that same district
so i'm just going to note you guys had
nancy pelosi
on the cover of magazines with ilhan
omar
okay ilhan omar is an open anti-semite
so is rashida talib they are both openly
anti-semitic
like repeatedly and openly you couldn't
even get accenture vote against those
against those congress people and the
head of your caucus
did magazine covers with those people
and they are cheered
wildly by the people in your in the
media constantly
okay marjorie taylor green does not have
a fan base
outside of her immediate constituency in
georgia okay
i'm i'm wondering who exactly is the
giant fan base
for marjorie taylor green and yet
marjorie taylor green is being treated
as though she is sort of the heroine of
the republican party these days i don't
know where i mean i do know where this
is coming from it's coming from a
motivated
media line of thought that says
republicans are their worst members and
democrats don't have bad members they
don't exist
so for example you're seeing this
barbara lee's democrat of course
and barbara lee she says on cnn of
course
that marjorie taylor green is a danger
she shouldn't serve in any legislative
body and it's just indicative of how bad
the republicans are that she's being
allowed to serve now a couple of things
one she's an elected congressperson
i don't believe that you can inject an
elected congress person based on
comments made before they were a
congress person once they're a congress
person
you can inject them based on on comments
that they make
but if you dig up something they said a
year ago presumably the people spoke
based on that information and but here's
barbara lee making this particular case
she is a danger she's a threat she
refuses to wear masks
she now of course we see which is to be
expected the support of donald trump
who incited violence who promoted
the attempted coup on january 6 and five
people died
and so she based on who she is her
behavior what she has said
it's she's a danger and should not serve
in uh
any legislative body so i agree she
never should have been elected
to congress i totally agree by the way
the comments that she is referring to
is that marjorie taylor green believes a
bunch of crazy crap because she kind of
crazy
now here's the stuff that she has said
according to the sacramento bee she
suggested
in a facebook post that the wildfires in
california
she says there are all these people who
have said they saw what looked like
lasers or blue beams of light
causing the fires and pictures and
videos
and apparently these lasers are
controlled by the jews
which is interesting the post claims
involvement from investor richard blum
husband of senator dianne feinstein and
the banking firm
rothschild inc so apparently she says if
they are beaming
the sun's energy back to earth i'm sure
they would never miss a transmitter
receiving station right i mean mistakes
are never made when anything new is
invented
what would that look like anyway a laser
beam or light beam coming down to earth
i guess could that cause a fire hmm i
don't know i hope not
that sure wouldn't look so good for pg e
rothschild zinc solarin or jerry brown
who doesn't seem fond
of pg and e um
she's also trafficked in q anon which is
crazy towns
um and she shared social media posts
asserting in 2018
that the parkland shooting was a false
flag operation
okay so she she's a nut she's a nutty
person who was elected
to congress because it was a a small
primary she's the only person who
received any sort of funding or media
attention
and next time around she should not be
elected right and if she says this sort
of stuff while she's in congress then
congress has every ability to eject her
from congress
certainly to censure her okay with all
of that said the attempt to paint
margery taylor green as the face of the
republican party is pretty obvious by
the media that is why there's all this
oppo focus on marjory taylor green right
now
see they can't do it for trump anymore
right trump's gone so now they have to
find a new face of the republican party
so are they gonna pick
one of the other faces of the republican
party they're gonna pick like dan
crenshaw
no of course not instead they're going
to take marjorie taylor green an attempt
to claim the entire republican party
is in fact marjorie taylor green and
suggest over and over that republicans
are
more worried about about the the normies
within the party than they are about the
march retailer greens within the party
so that's what chris wallace was doing
over the weekend on fox news
the fox news by the way brian stelter
would like to ban uh here's chris
wallace
saying that there is more focus on lynn
cheney in the republican party than
there is on marjory taylor green
which um i'm not sure how that is the
case considering that every single
republican member i have heard of has
condemned marjorie taylor green's
comments
in any case here's chris wallace you
know you've got a situation right now
where there is more
visible outrage inside the gop over
liz cheney a member of leadership voting
to impeach the president
over rather than some of these wild
conspiracy theories
being espoused by marjorie taylor green
how serious is this for the gop and what
can they do about it i mean they take
her off committees
expeller what what what are their
options here so a couple of things liz
cheney with regard to impeachment is
obviously doing something that's kind of
more important within the republican
power
party than this fringe nut from georgia
who believes in jewish space lasers
by the way i can't tell you more about
the jewish space laser
first rule of jewish space laser is you
never talk about jewish space
laser second rule of jewish space lover
a jewish space laser
and so we never roll on chavez those are
the two rules of jewish space laser
but aside from that but the reason
that republicans are maybe focused on
the controversy surrounding liz cheney
is because
impeachment is kind of a big thing and
liz cheney's the number three republican
in the house whereas this lady is a
first-term backbencher
from georgia who probably won't win
re-election in her district so maybe
that that is more of an issue in the
immediate term for the republican party
but the goal here of course
is that every republican is going to be
smeared with with marjorie taylor green
in the same way that every republican a
few years back was smeared with todd
aiken that is the way this works
okay you're gonna hear mtg margery
taylor green repeated over and over and
over again
and by the way because the left does
this this is what they do because the
left is going to spend an
inordinate amount of time the mainstream
media on this person that is going
to drive people into the arms of this
person because then people would be like
why is this person being unfairly
attacked why is she why are they
constantly talking about her
okay she's gonna end up with a larger
following which of course is exactly
what a lot of people want
a lot of people including archery taylor
green i would assume love that media
attention
because the media focusing on that means
a lot of people in reactionary fashion
will then go and defend martial retailer
green now two things can be true at once
one
she shouldn't be in congress she
believes a lot of crazy crap crazy crap
and two she is not a mainstream
republican voice
she is not the leader of any movement
she is not an important person in the
republican caucus
and she should be primary next time
around by a well-funded opponent
okay but that's not what the media's
designed here is to do the media's
design is to is to create
this this supposed imbalance between
craziness on the right and craziness on
the left
reality check there's craziness on both
sides the crazy people on both sides
need to be condemned i see actually more
condemnation from it very often on the
right than i do from people on the left
again
the left just wants to pretend away the
idea that there is any sort of
similarity between the craziness
okay the craziness extends across the
aisle i saw an entire democratic party
look the other way or cheer while cities
burn during the summer
and then when the capital rises happen
they're like why are you guys on the
right not condemning the violence more
strenuously
some of us condemn the violence both
times guys some of us thought it was
evil
both times some of you are just full of
crap
and when you do the same thing with mars
retailer green well you wrap your
large-scale democratic embrace around
ilhan omar and pretend that she's a
leading figure in your movement
i'm gonna say that you guys don't have a
leg to stand on when you talk about
anti-semitism in your own party
especially given the fact that your
entire critical race theory nonsense
is rooted in anti-semitic perceptions
about how jews are not actually a
victimized people
jews are actually just successful white
people now asians are turning into white
people thanks to critical race theory
so yeah i i don't buy any of your your
phony
insanity about this rando
weirdo crazy person yeah i i think that
it's a little bit i think it's a little
bit
convenient that you've decided to
elevate margery taylor green to the
leadership of the republican party based
on zero evidence that she's a member of
the leadership of the republican party
that is the goal here fringe everybody
by pointing at this by pointing at this
one person then that allows you to
basically silence anybody
and this is the part that's amazing
again to be mildly self-centered here
for a second
when politico when people say i
shouldn't have written for politico
because i'm a right-wing firebrand
okay let me just point out i'm maybe the
only person
on the right who said from the get-go
that trump didn't have evidence that
he'd won the election
okay so but that's and there's there's
nobody moderate enough
for these folks that's the point if you
disagree with them you are by nature
immoderate
that's the whole goal everybody is in
the same boat including the person who's
not even political
who just wants to go to work and be left
alone and go home and then
believe what they want about politics
they're not going to be allowed to do
any of that
okay meanwhile i will say that the
that the kind of nuttiness within the
republican party needs to be stopped and
it needs to be condemned
i think overall it has been but i think
that it will it needs
more always always more okay from both
sides would be great but
i'm a conservative so i would like to
see it in the republican party as well
so doug ducey the excellent governor of
arizona
he was censured by the state republican
party for no reason at all because kelly
ward
is the head of the state republican
party which is very foolish the state
party chairman
uh instead has been condemning ducey
the state republican party has been on
twitter you know signaling loyalty to
the idea that trump won the election
over and over or that
there was fraud in the state of arizona
which i don't believe was even alleged
by the trump campaign
and then they uh they tried to censure
ducey
for not going along with attempts to
overturn the election results so here is
juicy
chiding the state republican party by
the way no to arizona republicans if you
want to make that state blue
please continue doing what you're doing
if you would like the state to remain
read
you need to stop going along with the
with the people who are the fringes of
the fringe
passion does not mean strategic acumen
ducey happens to be an excellent
republican governor
of a purple state you don't want that
state to go blue maybe you should listen
to the guy who can actually win
statewide
this is a action of of very little
consequence
the party in arizona has had a long
history of
discontent this is just the latest
example
i think that the state party chairman
should focus on
winning races that should be a top
priority i
believe i was in good company in that
cartoon and i also want to say
i worked incredibly hard to deliver the
state
for donald trump and red up through
election day okay so meanwhile
things are getting radical over on the
abiding side of the alec and we're not
we're never going to talk about that
everything that biden does is going to
be treated as completely mainstream and
decent
in every possible way so let's talk
about that for a second
every single day the democrats are
rolling out more evidence that they are
more and more radical
and the media are going to treat this as
moderation they're going to just pretend
that nothing bad is is going on
so susan rice who's the domestic policy
advisor based on her vast experience
lying to the american public about
benghazi
she is the domestic policy advisor to
joe biden
and she was explaining to jonathan
capehart
who again is a a far-left guy he writes
for the washington post he's over on
msnbc
she's explaining to jonathan capehart
that when the biden administration says
things like racial justice and racial
equity
then that is not divisive now here's the
thing it's super divisive the reason
it's divisive is because it is thinking
of justice as a group thing
justice is not a group thing justice is
an individual thing the definition of
justice is you get what you deserve not
you get what your group deserves which
is inherently racially bigoted
and the idea that you get what your
group deserves why
why seriously but that is the case that
is being made over and over by the biden
administration here's susan rice saying
that this is actually unifying this is
the new unity guys they're not radical
this is all moderate
here's here's susan rice this is
actually the opposite of dividing us
this is about bringing everybody
everybody in and being inclusive
it's a bit rich to the republicans after
the 44 years of the most divisive
president ever
who use uh bigotry and hatred
as a political political strategy to
accuse a new administration that is
trying to include and lift up everybody
of divisiveness it's literally not
attempting to include and lift up
everybody if you are saying that certain
groups should be privileged above other
groups that is the exact policy that is
being proposed by the way even politico
is noting this today i didn't write
political guys it's okay you don't have
to get mad at politico
okay staffers at politico so they have
an entire piece
in the fabed fame the fabled famed
untouchable pristine politico playbook
okay about
the about the equity versus equality
routine that the biden administration is
doing
they say this they're all talking about
equity right this is the early buzzword
of the biden administration popping up
in nearly every policy proposal
executive order and speech by the
president and his top officials so far
they're all talking about equity not to
be confused with equality the umbrella
term that passed administrations
including barack obama's
used to describe efforts to address
racial and economic disparities
so what's this all about the idea in a
nutshell is this equality means every
person is treated the same
they get the same resources from the
government and same access to services
no matter what
well no equality generally means that
every person is treated the same
according to the rights that are
accorded to them
equity is an attempt to account for
differences in need among people from
disadvantaged backgrounds
even this is a bias no equity is an
attempt to
end with the same result for all groups
that's the goal right whereas kamala
harris put it two days before the
election
equality suggests oh everyone should get
the same amount the problem with that
not everybody's starting out from the
same place which sounds a lot like
communism right
everybody should end up with the same
amount the distinction is more than a
matter of semantics it is critical to
understanding
how the biden agenda is taking shape and
where it's heading in the months and
years to come
already equity is an organizing
principle of every policy prescription
biden has put forward so far from
housing to climate change don't worry
they're not radicals guys it's totally
fine
today i wrote about another example in a
story for politico say the editors of
playbook
black and brown people who are
disproportionately affected by the
coronavirus are also least likely to get
vaccinated there are lots of reasons why
but access to the internet to sign up
for shots and access to pharmacies and
hospitals to receive the shots is a big
one
simply giving all people access to
vaccination isn't enough biden officials
say
it will likely require deploying mobile
units to certain black and brown
neighborhoods among other targeted
actions to get the job done
okay no the actual critique of vaccine
policy
is not that in areas where there's
literally no ability to get vaccine we
should make sure that people can get
vaccine
the critique is that the cdc policy
originally recommended
that we vaccinate young african-american
people before 65 year old white people
which is
nuts okay that's crazy
now says politico conservatives have
taken notice of biden's embrace of
equity and are criticizing it as
affirmative action by a different name
that is what it is in push for woke
equity biden abandons equality read the
headline of new york post editorial over
the weekend
the equity approach assumes that any
outcome that doesn't meet inane racial
quotas is the result of bias
and in fact is systemically racist the
newspaper opined
senator tom cotton of arkansas i asked
hud secretary designate marcia fudge
about the difference during her
confirmation hearing on thursday
seemingly trying to get her acknowledged
that equity means treating people
differently based on their race
fudge's response quote you know if you
say to me that i'm gonna give you five
bucks
and you're gonna give my friend five
bucks my five bucks is not necessarily
gonna go this far because my friend
already has a mother and father who are
wealthy
shortly after cotton sent out an email
blast highlighting the exchange
signaling this could soon become
ammunition in washington's partisan
warfare
oh republicans pounds that's the problem
these republicans they won't accept the
idea
that we should basically segregate
people according to group and then treat
them according to group identity rather
than individually
by the way even fudge is fudging there
right the truth is in the united states
we already have means-based social
welfare programs
i do not receive any benefits from the
federal government people who are very
impoverished in the united states
receive
benefits from the federal government
that's not what this is about
when they say equity what they mean is
that they're going to judge you based on
your race
they're going to judge you based on your
history of racial victimization not
personally but as a group
so colin powell's kid should receive
five bucks and my kids should not
receive five bucks even though both are
growing up pretty wealthy
expect the debate says politico to shape
how some white americans in the middle
and on the right think about the biden
harris presidency
the left has recently embraced the shift
to equity and black and brown people
have been there for decades will biden
try to sell it to the public doesn't
look like it so far at least
administration officials are saying
equity a lot proposing policies they
think
reflect it and hoping that it clicks
well the reason that they are using the
term equity
as opposed to something like affirmative
action or quote unquote reparative
justice right that's the other one they
use reparative
justice because it's a reparation they
don't want to use that language they say
equity hoping that your brain will think
equality and then you'll just let it go
that's the goal here right just as just
as they've shifted
from disinformation to misinformation in
the media they can shut up people they
don't like
now they're shifting from equality to
equity in the hope that you don't know
the difference between equality and
equity because one has only one extra
syllable
basically and this has become the
talking point for every element of the
democratic agenda
over the weekend national climate
advisor jimmy mccart gina mccarthy she
said the environment is a racial justice
issue everything is a racial justice
issue
climate change is a racial justice issue
because it exacerbates the challenges in
the communities that have been left
behind
it goes after the very same communities
that pollution
has held back and racism is held back
and it's our opportunity to serve those
communities
to elevate them hey it's pretty amazing
and by the way the goal here the goal
here that racial justice and climate
justice are the same thing
the goal here is that if you then say
you oppose their program what what are
they going to call you
you know where it's going i don't like
your climate change program oh it's
cause you're a racist
you're a racist right because you're a
white supremacist you're defending the
white supremacist system this is why
whenever you hear anybody on the left
use the language anti-racist there's so
much semantic game playing here
when people on the left use the language
anti-racist they do not mean
opposes racism they mean opposes the
if you're anti-racist means opposes
quote unquote systems of racism
meaning any system that ends with a
racially disparate outcome
is a racist system and if you don't
oppose that system you are therefore
complicit in that system that's the
ibrahmax candy nonsense
how radical is this it's so radical that
over the weekend ibram kendy
was attacking john mchorder okay john
mcquarter is not a conservative
john mccarter is like a middle of the
road liberal
but now ibrahim kendi is basically
suggesting
that that john mcquarter needs to be run
out of polite society because he opposes
ibram x kenny's anti-racist fascistic
nonsense
and by the way it is absolutely
fascistic nonsense there's no question
about it
right ibra max kennedy has specifically
proposed i am not kidding you that there
be a national department at the federal
level in the executive branch
a national anti-racism department
capable of striking down
any state local or federal policy ending
with disparate racial outcome
okay with not an elected body just a
bunch of experts who basically rule
in order to achieve a a completely
equitable
arrangement at the top of politics now
kendy is going after john mccarter who
is a black
liberal okay like this is this is how
far this is going
so don't let them pretend that this is
all about
equality or it's about decency or it's
about liberty it absolutely is not
it absolutely is not instead
it is it is about ousting people you
disagree with even if you disagree with
them
kind of mildly on policy this prompted
by the way john mcquarter over the
weekend to tweet out stop pretending
about abram candy you're not alone in
finding his ideas primitive go with it
and walk on maybe even tell your friends
you don't get the hype
you'll likely find that they never did
either and quarter has an excellent
piece over at sub stack all about this
he uh he talked about at sub stack the
candy ideology and how it is
infusing so many places all across the
country
he says it's a great piece he says in my
atlantic article about anti-racism
manifestos that threaten to destroy
institutions of basic
missions as educational i mentioned that
the dalton school in new york was
considered
transform was considering transformative
anti-racism measures
however i have it on good authority that
in fact the damage was already done as
of last semester
here are some snapshots from dalton fall
2020 from concerned parents who because
if they went public with their names
they would be pilloried as bigots
nationwide are staying anonymous
quote every class this year has had an
obsessive focus on race and identity
racist cop reenactments in science
decentering whiteness in art class
learning about white supremacy and
sexuality in health class by the way not
rare at the dalton school
in california i believe it's at
brentwood school somebody sent an email
to me
that showed that kids are being separate
parents
are being separated by race for actual
parent-teacher conferences
they're having like a white parent's
night and a black parent's night this is
in line with equity it's all equity
honestly the segregation is from 1955 or
just clapping and glee in their graves
now the elect
my term for the hyperworks woke says
john mcquarter who are hijacking
constructive leftist ideals in this
nation
will claim that this sort of thing is
exactly what education needs to be
and that white or white parents who
object are displaying fragility
however we get that fragility notion
from one of the worst books ever written
as i have argued what dalton is doing is
tragic and grisly
by the way i cannot resist noting that i
hear on good authority that professor
robyn deangelo has claimed
she is the neil degrasse tyson to my
astrologer i will only say that quite a
few presented within the three of us
would find me moroccan if only
superficially to tyson for certain
reasons
neil degrasse tyson's black mcquarter is
black deangelo's white
he says in the atlantic piece i wrote of
how anti-racist protests shut down bryn
mawr last semester
the protest actually spread to allied
schools haverford and swarthmore i have
it on good authority that at swarthmore
the president simply folded arms and
said no to the protesters upon which
they basically folded in their tails
and went away why because the president
is a black woman valerie smith
the key is here this is the key she knew
she could respond to melodramatic
performance art with the refusal it
deserved because no one could call her
racist
and this is the point that he's making
is that again the redefinition of racism
from has animus on the basis of race to
you don't agree with my agenda
that that that transformation is vile
and dangerous
he says i don't mean that being against
racism is bs i mean that a certain
strain of quote-unquote anti-racism
these days is bs
and that's right for just saying this
candy wants basically mcquarter barred
from the public conversation
and that's what that's the exact
ideology that has been now being
embraced by the biden administration get
ready for it
this is the danger of the biden
administration not specifically the
policies they enact which will be bad
the stuff that's actually dangerous from
the biden administration is going to be
the ideology they put forward it was an
ideology first put forward during the
obama years it is being revivified
much more deeply and in hyper-partisan
fashion by the biden administration
by the way if you think these people
have the the best
anything these people have the best
interests of all americans at heart
remember biden
you know during his inaugural he said
i'm here for unity and i'm i'm here
because
you know i want i'm going to stand for
all americans right unity and all
and all this stuff i don't think that
his administration has all americans in
mind
just the latest indicator kamala harris
the most wondrous of all vice presidents
right just incredible at her job she did
an interview over the weekend
in which she has all americans mind she
deeply cares about all americans
and the biden administration's
environmental plans are going to wreck a
bunch of jobs
in places like west virginia because of
their attempts to shut down
carbon emissions okay here is kamala
harris who obviously cares about
everyone so caring
so knowledgeable completely botching
west virginia
mining policy you will hear her in this
clip refer to abandoned mine lands
as landmines because she is so
knowledgeable and understanding and
really takes all americans concerned
seriously
job creation around for example all of
those
skilled workers who are in the coal
industry
and and and transferring those skills to
what we need to do
in terms of dealing with reclaiming
abandoned
um uh landmines what we need to do
around
plugging leaks from oil and gas wells
and and transferring
those important skills to the work that
has yet to be done that needs to get
done
oh abandon we do need those uh those
west virginians
out there ensuring that we what
somehow failed to trigger the abandoned
land mines
it's like the demilitarized zone in
korea well well done there kamala harris
only the experts only the experts all
right we'll be back here later today for
an additional hour of programming in the
meantime
go check out the michael knowles show he
discusses redditer's buying a billboard
in times square you can hear more
details about that story over on
michael's show it's available everywhere
right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling production
manager pavo wiedowsky
our associate producers are rebecca
doyle and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
if you want to cut through the madness
of our politics and culture and know
what's
really going on and what it really means
head on over to the michael knowles show
where we can all bask in the simple joys
of being right
see you there